hi I've run these tickets on Instagram I
saw that she had this competition and I
thought it was really cool and I was
like why not let's go for it we're gonna
get married the day before and we did
and she by five five five
hello everybody today we are in downtown
LA and we are going to the eat show and
my co-host who will not be speaking
today is my lovely future wife I'm an
act all gang we recently went intimidate
delegate of the comedy Rose at that
roast I was laughing so hard and like
cheering sword the next day I woke up
and I could not use loud as I could it
hurts my throat when I use my poison so
just was praying for me that was the
first time I heard her voice in my 24
hours it sounds crazy
she's been drinking tea honey with lemon
all that kind of stuff and tonight when
we get back home after each show I'm
gonna make her some chicken soup with
some ginger and garlic that's what they
say is healthy for a sore throat yeah
you can't talk but can you eat I feel
like I need a whisper when I talk to you
it's kind of like the whole if you're
talking to someone that is a really nice
and like bubbly hey how you doing it oh
my gosh I'm having a great day but
you're like oh yeah you are too old me
to keep reminding him you don't need a
whisper nicely to Isaac get whispering
to me which by the way today Isaac daddy
cuz it's a weekend
true dat now we're gonna go eat again
and breather waiting present
[Music]
Blosser okay oh no these are made power
[Music]
I just want to eat it off the glass what
can I do for you guys today
three hey I got this alright let me take
care that for you guys alright
this Cheston I'm getting a message from
tip okay laughs beverages look at all
the beverages you can drink
I'll Drive okay I'm going to drink that
all right so I didn't eat before come
over actually I did I ate McDonald's
breakfast first thing in the morning
make sure not to eat anymore after that
breakfast I'm starving
did you guys use I didn't do anything I
woke up and I came here because I was
late Vinnie I saw banana and I was like
should I but then I was like oh thank
you
[Music]
what the middle of your faces what we
really are what Skinner
first stop Italian food Maggiano's the
general Maggiano's was one of my first
date my first fancy date place never
been to with a girl
and now I'm here too
[Music]
there's something weird in there it
looks like a parasite almost oh look
it's a little brown it's a baby crab I
think it came just like straight from
the ocean I don't really want to eat it
yeah all right on to the next food item
block water
how's it different
fresh
whosh bitter water
better water
what is this one lamb and pork toe stop
oh yeah whatever Isum
[Music]
Oh
I've ever had in my life
[Music]
it was so good I was eating so fast that
I choked on it I should practice not
thinking like barbarians
I know I know I know I know
[Music]
like you doesn't care
Tiffani's you know I know I'm at the
Blue Ranger
yeah the Blue Ranger got to fight it out
Blue Ranger blue hair I know easy who in
which she has no voice so I can encode
you destroyed
I am actually very prolific I need any
know where it is all right this is what
I've been waiting for my favorite
barbecue all right it's pretty hard to
vlog today because we're all holding
these trade that's a food item that
requires you to be some sort of an
artist to actually create and execute on
the regular to one after another
good
McFlurry was all experienced so far it
was good everyone was happy because
everyone was eating food sad I had to go
to my car and like
oh forget the meter I hope I don't get a
ticket so I'll see you later
although you're about to kiss my hand
blast I'm gonna try some Seoul sausage
over like a sushi it's a sausage soon
good new fire right for Kelly
softly scream
Oh
[Music]
like you're shooting a commercial for
them
we came across is drink company they
harvest all the nutritional value of
like all the stuff of these all the
different flavors that they incorporate
for the drink so this one is a
Marie the lady was telling us that
napkin for sore throat recommended
covering for us
[Music]
my voice just came back what
that's crazy I was whispering and Kewpie
we're I was trying to tell them that I
really like the milk brand that the cost
per one and
kept trying to whisper louder I thought
my voice come back into this I was like
oh my god oh my god I went back what
this thing is crazy
I'm crediting it all to this because I
could feel it like soothing my
totally not sponsored by the way it
works yeah we're totally not sponsored I
don't even know what this company's name
is people tentacle
you guys are Paul I finally can speak
I'll never take my voice for granted
again
[Music]
liquid nitrogen frozen popcorn changes
the taste and the texture and it's like
nothing you've ever had before
so go ahead out while it's still fun
it's not good for micro but it's okay
we're going now
okay so first we're standing in this
really really long line so hopefully we
finish all this like time we get to the
front we only have like a few more
minutes are like less than an hour here
we have to go
we're all excited to get in each line
drive the ride which is food I'd rather
do this and get the big adults pretty
fun
when do you think your mind switch from
being I think like a kid and I like get
up and kiss on this butter - I like
growing up stuff and being an adult and
doing stuff like this is fun I think
maybe last year I've always felt again
maintain that little girl inside of me
especially with pi/6 is like having a
kid especially at a young age it's like
really easy to keep the inner child
alive but then like now like like
pysical since that's how every weekend
we get to really see like we get to see
what it's like to be an adult and like
to actually do like this don't us
without a kid I don't I think it's fun
the Bennett I don't feel like screaming
little children everywhere
like whiny okay nevermind I guess you
still have a kid me doing it acting like
they're trying to kick us out yeah she
came so late you got to try one like
like one one row I'm like forever Mayo
but enjoy them but you don't want those
clogged because let's look at all the
other booths and I think I made the
right decision to try that side because
the best food was over there yeah I know
there's actually I didn't talk too much
I told you the whole story the whole
spiel
anyway so we're gonna head back home so
we didn't plan anything else to do for
the rest of the day I think we should
break out one of the toys I bought
recently we wanted to test out that new
toy oh my god this sounds so wrong it's
actually a drone guys it's a drone we
wanted to alright so we recently bought
a drone to practice on so we bought a
DJI phantom 3 an older generation drone
why did we buy an older one the thing I
know about flying drones and I'm a big
fan of Katie nice dad stuff you know I
consider him like the godfather of
vlogging and he goes through drones like
no other you know like he says he has
seven drones all of them have you know
crashed at one point or another knowing
that fact about his experience with
drones and then knowing a few friends of
mine that actually do fly drones flying
a drone is actually very very
complicated it's not as easy as it looks
it's an actual skill yeah and so I want
to learn how to fly a drone she wants to
learn how to fly a drone and we figured
well if it's gonna go through the hands
of two people learning it's for sure
gonna crash eventually I think let's
it's five drone today cool and it's like
my first time holding it actually really
since we got it yeah alright so met up
with my friend a.k.a k so up mess up a K
is a very important person in my life
actually it really you really are cuz
without you I don't think I would have
made the move to LA - yeah well I I
think we all we've both convinced each
other I think without each other we
wouldn't have made the move down to LA
because we needed a support system you
know and then us - along with J Jeon is
another director friend of ours we all
moved out to LA together and we became
our own little support system to kind of
motivate each other to keep pushing
forward with the whole Hollywood grind
and whatnot and so thank you for
Thank You cousin oh yeah thanks to you
thank you we miss ya so today what are
we doing okay today we are testing out
Casey's new DJI phantom 3 and you know
we're gonna try to become pilots today
to your dream at one point was to become
a pilot yeah when I was little I always
wanted to be a pilot and fly a plane
because I just love flying and like the
feeling of flying in your dreams and
like just flying in a plane all that
stuff so this is the closest thing I'll
get to be Capelli yeah I'm pretty
excited I want to learn how to fly a
drone
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
we didn't cross it the first time I know
well there's nothing to crash it in a
hunt hard here successful flight
successful flights well it was while I
was flying though looks like it right
into something cuz there's like little
specks that looked like blood we hit a
parrot I don't know we didn't hit her I
think it was like little bugs or
something cuz look it's like all six
splashes of glitters well they probably
hit a mosquito oh yeah look I probably
chopped the mosquito in half and then
all that's other people's blood right
here oh right here this one it was this
blade right there a mosquito died right
there and that's other people's blood I
gotta wash my hands